[Music]
hi I'm roll pizza and I'm Nathan we're
plant science students at Cornell
University who are ancient city
understanding helped us extend
themselves and understand that you too
can help today we're going to share with
you some information about iron and
acquiring nutrient for both plants and
humans we wouldn't have food if it
wasn't for agriculture it is the basis
of our civilization so advances in food
production are extreme importance
certain eras have defined and changed
agriculture and human history these are
known as our cultural revolutions the
first agriculture revolution was a
transition from hunting and gathering to
planting and sustaining the second was
the addition of mechanization in
harvesting transportation and marketing
the third was the implementation of
technologies such as fertilizers the use
of high yielding seeds and improved
irrigation methods in summary this
produced more food and energy in the
form of calories but there was also a
decrease in the concentrations of
nutrients including Erin this ultimately
caused for people to have enough food
but not enough nutrition
irons an element that
to our body whose red color is analogous
to blood and is cemented into many
ideologies as a sign of health and vigor
due to its unique properties iron plays
a critical role in DNA synthesis
respiration and many other complex that
pathways of photosynthesis this nutrient
is relatively abundant energy Christ
about five percent but not all of it
it's available to plants and all plants
have the amazing capability of
transforming inorganic materials to
organic once they need help this is a
prominent issue that affects iron
absorption from plants towards humans
this causes major problems for global
health special because most of the
Earth's population is a plant-based diet
animal products especially organ meats
do an amazing job at reap leading ones
iron reserves like liver and tongue but
for my plant-based peeps fermented soy
products like tofu and leafy green
vegetables are an excellent source of
non heme iron and contain other
nutrients as well
one can also boost iron absorption by
consuming iron rich foods with vitamin C
I personally have a stir fried tofu with
lots of veggies when I'm feeling low on
iron
achieving adequate iron intake is a
challenging task with iron being such an
abundant mineral in the Earth's crust
why do plants have such a difficult time
acquiring the appropriate amounts well
part of the answer lies in the soil
environment where iron is found unevenly
distributed and bound to other minerals
this uneven distribution can lead to
iron deficiency which can be recognized
when the spaces between young leaf veins
begin to yellow if left untreated the
whole leaf will yellow and the plant
will die further up the food chain the
effects of low iron can be devastating
for humans that consume less than what
they need iron deficiency in humans can
result in stunted brain development in
children as well as iron deficiency
anemia which can produce severe fatigue
and enhance other infections and
diseases
iron deficiency affects up to 30% of the
global population particularly those who
rely on plant-based diets that are low
in dietary iron however the effects of
iron deficiency anemia are more likely
to be prevalent in historically
marginalized populations whose access to
quality food and healthcare treatment is
limited by income geography and politics
since our a is so important for both
plants and humans let's move on to how
plants and humans get the oil we have
talked about the two oxidation states of
RA and the plants have developed
strategies to take up both of them for
diagnose and on grass Monica's such a
petunia a cucumber the synthesizer
enzyme called ferric killakee reductase
which can convert the RN 3 to R into at
the root surface and the plants take up
the iron to by our transporter into root
epidermal cells for grasses such as
maize and rice they release a compound
to codify to settle force which could
bind iron 3 and be taken up as a complex
by transporters in the epidermis within
the plans arrays transported upwards in
a special vascular tissue called the
xylem and I will be partitioned and
loaded into the flan another specialized
vascular tissue which transports iron to
different destinations such as the young
leaves seeds and even go back to the
root plants are also smart enough to
seize the changing environment and
according to their roots and issues to
work together for efficient iron uptake
due to the complicates our environment
it is not hard to imagine a plant
growing in the soil with uneven
distribution of nutrients such as our
what will happen part of their rows will
be stronger than others to increase
nutrient foraging
to achieve these responses to the
unbalance the environment plants
actually developed a labor additionally
night work behind this common phenomena
basically both aren't efficient and are
sufficiently rude parties will send a
signal to the chute to report their iron
status the chute will process all the
information and send signals back to
Bruce to tell the are insufficient parts
there are some places need RL
then they are insufficient parts will
develop more laterals and upregulate the
Arabic genes they are loaded into the
plant edible parts will be consumed by
humans even though there are abundant
our element in nature not all of them
are available to be taken up by plants
even though plants can take up enough
iron for their growth maybe they are not
enough are in the edible parts of a
human diamond the concept of
biofortification has been developed in
order to increase the density of mineral
nutrients in head about issues they
approaches include enhancing iron
accumulation in seeds by introducing the
iron storage protein modifying our end
distribution or improving the iron
uptake
[Music]
if you remember a plant from the
foundation of our diet so challenges and
plant health can become challenges in
human health going forward understanding
how plants take up use and store mineral
nutrients will help us provide
nutritious food
[Music]
you
[Music]